nous ne sommes pas ici les acteurs d'une
pièce de théâtre nous ne sommes pas là
pour traficoter la démocratie
user d'articles jamais
usité du tréfond d'un règlement nous ne
sommes pas là pour mettre à mal toute la
jurisprudence de notre assemblée ou
jouer aux bonnes taux en changeant en
dernière minute dans la nuit les députés
de cette commission pour y mettre de
bons petits soldats qui lèveront la main
lorsqu'on leur demandera
[Musique]
oui c'est une proposition de loi pour
sortir de la crise politique et de la
crise sociale provoquer par le recours
aux 49-3 à l'occasion du vote de la
réforme des retraites que le
gouvernement s'est obstiné à mettre en
oeuvre puisqu'il est devenu à la mode de
redécouvrir notre Constitution à
l'occasion du recours un certain nombre
de ces articles qu'il s'agit de
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de l'article 44
alinéa 3 plus connu sous le nom de votre
bloqué de l'article 47 1 ou encore de
l'article 40 je voulais en citer un qui
a curieusement disparu des débats
l'article 24 le Parlement vote la loi
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
totalement c'est le fameux article
magique cet article abracadabra qui va
faire passer l'âge de 64 à 62 pour rien
parce que on suppose qu'un article 2
trouverait une solution miraculeuse que
personne n'a trouvé jusqu'ici de
financement je rappelle que si l'on
passe de 74 à 62 ans en pratique cela
signifie que la pension moyenne pour un
Français
baissera de 900 euros par an tout le
monde fait dans cette salle que jamais
cette proposition ne sera votée au Sénat
tout le monde sait dans cette salle que
cette proposition est
inconstitutionnelle
les charges induites par l'article
premier de ce texte s'élève à 18
milliards d'euros par an le président de
la commission des finances doit être le
garant de l'article 40 or il ne sait pas
comporter comme le gardien de l'ordre
constitutionnel qu'il doit être mais
comme un militant politique vous le
savez mes chers collègues et le
président de la commission des finances
Éric Coquerel ne cessent de le rappeler
fort justement cet article 40 qui vise à
retoquer des propositions de loi au
motifs qu'elles engagent de nouvelles
dépenses n'aies d'ordinaire pas utilisé
pour les propositions de loi et
d'ailleurs celle sur le Bien Vieillir
déposé par les macronistes par le groupe
Renaissance coûtait 8 milliards d'euros
et elle n'a pas été retoquée alors
faut-il nous habituer mes chers
collègues avoir les droits des
oppositions bafouées le vote de notre
assemblée contourné pour 38 contre 34
abstention 1 et donc les amendements de
suppression sont adoptés en conséquence
l'article premier est supprimé
[Musique]